- Faites attention, ne restez pas là.
Le vent glacé souffle en rafales à plus de 120 km/h.
La municipalité vient de déclarer l'état d'urgence.
Les habitants ont interdiction de sortir de chez eux.
Derrière leurs fenêtres.
Certains assistent au spectacle d'une nature déchaînée.
- Mon Dieu, le toit tombe !
Le toit tombe !
- Bonsoir, bienvenue sur les ondes du télé canal de Russie.
Le programme d'information sur Norilsk.
Norilsk qui est actuellement touché par une forte vague de tempête.
Il y a au moins 3 victimes, des piétons.
L'un d'eux est décédé.
- Le vent est puissant.
Il faut rester chez vous.
Ne sortez pas , même pour acheter du pain.
La tempête a ravagé une partie de la ville.
- Regarde ce que le vent a fait.
Ca peut tomber, ça .
- Qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé, Sergueï ?
-Il y a eu des bourrasques de vent et
elles ont littéralement arraché le toit de l'immeuble.
C'est vraiment dangereux.
- La ferraille du toit vole comme ça au dessus des gens, des voitures.
C'est effrayant.
Sergueï et sa famille ne sont pas les seuls à ignorer les consignes de sécurité.
- Prenons 2 briques de lait.
Cette marque-là, c'est bien ?
- Oui, comme ça.
Nous sommes obligés de faire vite parce que l'aéroport est fermé ,
et bientôt, il n'y aura plus d'approvisionnement, ici.
C'est pour ça que nous devons acheter beaucoup.
Chéri, prends l'huile, la grosse bouteille.
Le blizzard signifie la fermeture de l'aéroport et
donc la rupture du ravitaillement de la ville.
Car à Norilsk, aucune culture ni d'élevage.
Tout est importé, sauf le poisson.
- Et là, vous allez pouvoir tenir combien de jours ?
- Si on se fie à notre expérience, le
blizzard ne devrait pas durer plus de 5 jours.
Je pense que nous aurons assez de provisions jusqu'à la fin de la tempête.
A l'extérieur, la tempête semble sur le point de se lever à nouveau.
Après 5 jours de bourrasques incessantes, le passage de
la tempête est visible à chaque coin de rue.
La catastrophe climatique a fait 2 morts.